[Musique]
on le voit bien parce que je le
répéterai pas deux fois
on tient ton fils en otage ok mais c'est
pas d'appeler la police sinon on le but
direct ok on veut 150000 euros en
coupures
sinon on bute ton fils oui comme ça il
en face de toi ah non il a raccroché pas
de michael c'est bien numéro de ton père
satan gj confondues monsieur bah j'ai
confondu le 1 et le set
ouais ouais non mais attends tu as vu
comment il décrit aussi la regarde on
n'a pas appris à écrire l'école rien
n'est pas de mouche non non c'est
clairement un set là ça se voit que
c'est un set
oui bonjour je suis bien au 07 61 55 81
10 super six écoute moi bien parce que
je le répèterai pas deux fois
on tient ton fils en otage ne s'est pas
d'appeler la police sinon au but direct
on veut cinquante mille euros
cent cinquante mille euros au aux
petites coupures écoute moi bien on
attend fils en otage un site une fille
pas 150000 euros
on va lui faire très mal on va lui péter
les deux jours et un vrai musée ce qu'on
va les faire non eh ben je te donne la
vie dit il dictait qu'un petit con un
petit con cas jamais rien foutu que tu
as mais elle aurait honte de toi et tu
peut te [ __ ] l'avantagé au cul oh oui
arrive pas il propose vingt balles il
raccroche et ça
moi mon père il m'a jamais dit je t'aime
hockey et regarde mon année maintenant
strad from the world as we un rappel le
non non je vais pas rappeler
franchement il avait l'air énervé non ok
le rappelle pas ça rate pas on va
appeler ta mère fils ou son numéro et
non pas ma mère pitié pas ma mère
pourquoi mais parce qu'elle va me tuer
si elle a conclu la juge ait promis ne
pas sortir et de réviser mes partiels
ok ok donc nous on a des fringues et
cette amère qui fait peur parce
monumenta mer mais non mais vraiment ça
sert à rien ma mère est les aztèques mon
père il lui a rien laissé après le
divorce alors ça t'a bien quelqu'un qui
t'aime un peu dans ta famille chez une
grand mère un peu freak et qui
voudraient bien payer pour sauver la vie
créée nous sauver la vie accessoirement
parce qu'elle est notre beau ça va nous
tuer si on met de ballack banon même mes
grands parents ils sont marc aux noms
comme en même temps si tu perds tu
restes là non c'est pas triste moi aussi
son bord des grands parents je vais très
bien à mes potes à grands pas c'est pour
ça que tu les a jamais présenté en fait
pourquoi tout la bouche tout en fait
pourquoi tu essayes de parler moi
j'essaie de nous sortir de là j'essaie
de trouver une solution et toi toi tu
parles c'est chiant c'est triste bon on
prend à la limite toi pas d'étude si je
crois que j'ai vingt balles
ben non il me reste plus que 6 50 parce
que j'ai payé un kebab du coup un kebab
à 13 euros 50 donc bah oui c'était une
assiette hockey parce que je sais faire
et c'est toi tu as fait trop oui il faut
moi j'ai peut-être une idée
oui ok situation sous contrôle
aucune trace des ravisseurs et pas de
blessé parmi les otages en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que on était dans la
rue puis on a vu un type sortir d'une
camionnette et puis enlevez lui qu'à le
tiff à l'heure à 10 heures ils nous a
vus pizza break avec un flingue et c'est
pour ça qu'on attache et ici à le cas là
c'est vrai
oui c'est vrai tout ce qu'on vous
raconte on est des otages ok on n'a
jamais dit le contraire ça va ça va on
s'est fait kidnapper
j'ai bien compris ça
pour appeler la bosse il à prévenir que
ça s'est pas passé comme prévu
ok tu l'appelles je l'appelle je
l'appelle
[Musique]
oui à l'eau aux fins de madame excusez
moi pardon je suis trompé bonne soirée
là je suis encore ton petit mais c'est
mon téléphone aussi décolle pas dû faire
c'est le boss l appel qu est ce que je
vous dis rien compris espèce de débile
c'est sa mère la bosse alors je veux
plus jamais entendre parler de vous
attend il y avait combien de % de
chances pour que la bosse soit la mère
de lucas n'a pas de pot rappelle moi
pourquoi je t'aime toi en fait tu as ton
père c'est vraiment un crevard mêlant
les deux là c'est vraiment des béraud
tel nom la semaine prochaine on se
rentrait pas tâté du sud elle est plein
de thunes et amador ouais ça elle est
naïve ont très vite
tu peux voir le premier épisode en
cliquant là et si tu veux un troisième
épisode du like tu partages et tu mets
un petit commentaire gentil oui parce
qu'on aimerait bien le tourné à las
vegas le prochain va vraiment falloir
que la vidéo et marche très très très
bien